PROFESSOR: All right!
Welcome back to 6849.
Today, we're going to
move into linkage folding.
And before we get there, I
want to talk about an issue
that sort of motivates
linkage folding.
And it's about the
definition of folding.
So we've talked
about origami a lot,
and we've talked
about crease patterns,
and we've talked about
the folded state-- which
is the finished product
after you fold something.
But there's another thing
we might care about.
So whenever we wanted
to prove that we could
fold a piece of paper
in a particular way,
we described a folded state.
We said what does the
paper look like in 3D,
how are the layers stacked,
all these kinds of issues.
But when you fold a
real piece of paper,
you start from a
flat thing, and you
want to continuously deform
it into some 3D shape.
And that is another
kind of folding,
which we call a folding
motion, which we haven't really
worried about up until now.
And it's going to be the central
concept in linkage folding.
The way to define
a folding motion
is just a continuum
of folded states.
It's a movie.
You start somewhere, usually
we start from the flat folded
state, and then at all times
we specify a new folded state,
a new way to fold
a piece of paper.
As long as that's a
continuous process,
then that is a folding motion.
So we've done all
this work proving
that folded states exist.
The question is, what if
I want a folding motion?
Because really, in
order to fold the paper,
I've got to get there.
And that's we're
going to worry about
for the first few minutes.
The good news is the reason we
haven't worried about this up
'till now is there's an
equivalence between the two
for paper folding.
So if you have-- it's called
a simple polygonal piece
of paper, and that
just means your piece
of paper some polygon,
but it has no holes in it.
It's sort of solid,
there's nothing like this.
Then, it has a folding motion
into any desired folded state.
So you say, I don't know.
I have this folded state
where all the lines of a swan
are aligned in that
second fold and cut.
How do I actually fold
into that folded state?
It's possible.
Any folded state
we describe, you
can reach by a folding motion.
So we're going to prove this.
When you look at it the right
way it's almost trivial,
but maybe a little confusing.
So I'll describe the proof to
see what you think about it.
I'm going to start with the
case of one dimensional paper,
because it's always
easier to think about.
The idea is the following.
You have a piece of paper, and
you have some folded state.
I'm going to draw
a little letter
m, what you want
to fold it into.
They should have
the same length.
We're given this map, we're
told how the piece of paper
folds-- in this case
into two dimensions--
and if there were
any touching layers
here it would be described
which is on the top of which.
We're told how to
instantaneously go
from here to here.
What we're not told is
the steps in between,
and that's what we're
going to fill in over here.
So the idea is rolling creases.
I have my piece of
paper here, and I'm just
going to curl in the
end a little bit.
So I'm going to fold
this thing into--
or I just roll up the end,
I can do this continuously.
It's sort of like the
real piece of paper.
If you start folding
and then pull,
I continuously roll that crease.
At all times, in fact, this
is supposed to stay flat.
It's really hard to
get started in reality,
but in theory, you
can get started
with an infinitesimal
part of the crease.
You just roll it in.
So you make the piece
of paper smaller.
It will be-- geometrically
these are on top of each other,
so it'll be tiny.
So it'll actually be a subset
of the original piece of paper.
You keep doing this,
you end up, let's say,
with a rolled up piece
of paper like that.
A little hard to draw.
Really, it lies along
the line segment,
and you're just going around
and around in a line segment.
But it's like a cinnamon bun.
Why do we bother?
Well, if we look at a tiny
piece of this folding--
so in fact I should have
done this at the beginning,
let me do that now--
away from the creases.
If I look at a tiny portion,
it's nice and smooth.
I'm not at a crease.
I'm going to highlight which
portion of the paper here ends
up-- this piece of paper's
roughly in quarters.
This is like the third quarter--
that ends up over here.
What I'd really like to
do is roll up everything
to lie on top of that,
so I do some rolling.
Maybe this is the-- and
I'm going to roll this up.
So I end up with
the thick segment,
and then some stuff
rolled on top of it.
I don't really care too much
what it looks like, I just
need that there's a
continuous rolling process
to get everything to lie
on top of that segment.
Now what I do going down--
this is all in one dimension.
All of this lies
in one dimension.
Now we're going to go
into the second dimension.
Exciting.
So we imagine that there's this
M, the folded shape that we
want to build.
And we're going to place it
where the thick part belongs,
where that highlighted
part belongs.
So it belongs
here, and of course
everything comes
along for the ride.
So you've got a little roll
here and a bigger roll here.
Something like that.
Just taking that-- or I guess
they were all on the same side,
I'm not drawing
very consistently.
OK, but it's all lying along
this segment of the M. Now
I just need to unroll.
This is where for
the mathematicians
this will become obvious
in a little while.
Maybe, I don't know.
It's kind of a common trick.
So we have this motion
that got us here.
We can obviously play
that motion backwards.
It's symmetric, I could unroll
just as easily as I rolled.
But now what I want to do is
not unroll in one dimension--
if I did that, I'd end
up lying along the line
segment extending this old part.
Actually, it's not
even quite straight,
but let's pretend
it's kind of straight.
But now I want to unroll along
the M. So unrolling here,
the first thing I would
unroll is this stuff.
It's going to go along the
long direction, the left side.
So it's going to unroll
along, and but instead
of going straight, I want
it to just move along
the M. It's like
I'm an ant, and I
don't realize that I live in
this two dimensional space.
I'm going to pretend that I live
on this one dimensional space,
even though it's not
physically there yet.
That's why I drew it dashed.
I just unroll.
So I'll end up by the
end-- at this point
I will have this half
of the M, the bold part,
and then this half of the
M hasn't been made yet.
And I'll have a little roll
that's enough to make that.
I unroll more, and I
end up going there.
So it's kind of crazy.
Just roll up the
piece of paper so it's
super tiny so you can put
it on the folded state
without having any creases,
then undo everything
you did, but living on the
surface instead of in the line.
So you may or may not believe
that works, but it works.
It's kind of cool.
You can generalize that
to two dimensional paper.
It's a little harder
to draw the diagram,
so I bring the textbook.
Here we have a polygon
of paper, but same idea.
We're going to roll
up that piece of paper
until it's super
tiny-- in this case,
super tiny is a little triangle.
We identify--
actually, ahead of time
we identify a portion, a little
triangle on the surface here,
that does not hit any creases.
Here it is.
And so we roll up the paper to
be contained in that triangle.
Of course, there's
many layers above it,
which you can't-- it's
hard to draw here.
You just curl that
triangle a little bit.
Now it lives on the crane.
Here, we're supposing
we want to get
a continuous motion
of the crane.
It's multiple layers,
all sorts of fun things.
And then you just
keep on rolling,
just like you did in the
top thing but backwards.
And instead of
living in the plane,
you now live on
the crane surface.
And the mapping between
them is given to you.
You're given the folded
state that tells you
how the piece of paper
lives on the crane,
and so you just undo
everything on the crane,
instead of in the plane.
On the crane instead
of in the plane--
should be a Doctor Seuss.
Yeah, question.
How do I pick the region?
I just-- in general, we
have some crease pattern.
I just take some region
interior to one face
of the crease pattern.
So just avoiding
creases is all I want.
Yeah.
The level of detail in
describing any region will do.
In reality, we want
it small, so that's
almost flat by smoothness.
But that's sort of
a technical detail.
Other questions?
How many people does
this make sense to?
Just curious.
Yeah, almost everyone
kind of makes sense.
Good.
You have to see it a few times.
I remember giving a talk
of this paper in 2001,
and I sort of understood it, but
it was a very interactive talk.
People kept asking questions.
I think by the end
everyone understood it.
Now I understand it.
It's good stuff.
There's some important
open questions, though.
This crucially relies on--
this maybe not so-- well, yeah.
If you had a hole in your piece
of paper, this would not work.
Because you can't reduce--
you can't get rid of the hole
by folding.
And you can do all sorts
of rolling, folding corners
over, and making
this thing smaller,
but you'll never be able
to get rid of that hole.
And so this approach
breaks down.
Also, if your piece
of paper was a cube,
the surface of the cube--
like, the end the last class
we talked about
flattening, we had a cube,
and you want to
collapse it flat.
There we know that
there's a folded state,
but we don't know about
the folding motions.
It's kind of disconcerting.
We presume there's
a folding motion,
but again, this
approach doesn't work
because you can't get a cube
down to a tiny triangle.
You can't get rid of the--
it's kind of like having holes,
but you surround a hole
in the case of the cube,
and you can't get rid of that
topological feature by folding.
So it's tricky.
We avoid collision
throughout here.
We also crease
basically every point.
This is rather impractical
if you actually
want to make something.
It's comforting,
theoretically, but this is not
how you actually fold
a crane, because you
have to do all this
continuous crease rolling.
So over time, every
point of paper
is at some point on a crease.
And a big open problem
is what can you
do with finitely many creases?
I'll write that down.
Let's suppose you have no
overlapping layers of paper,
to make life a
little bit easier.
So the paper doesn't
touch itself, so to speak.
Can you do a finite
number of extra creases?
I would conjecture
maybe yes, but this
is a challenging problem.
Here we have sort of
infinitely many creases.
Everything becomes a crease.
The extreme form
of this is what we
call rigid origami, where
you have no extra creases.
So you're supposed to
just use the creases that
are given to you in
the crease pattern,
and the faces of the crease
pattern are rigid polygons.
They have to stay flat
throughout the folding motion.
So rigid origami
is a thing about
ridge-- about folding motions,
not about folded states.
I have some folded
state I want to get to,
can I get there
with rigid polygons?
And the creases now
become hinges, basically.
If you're making
origami out of metal
with flat sheets,
or plastic polygons,
whatever, hinging them together.
Can use still fold this thing?
Or did folding it
require this kind
of bending the
paper in crazy ways,
putting creases
all over the place?
Sometimes you can do this,
most of the time you can't.
And there's a lot we don't
know about rigid origami.
I have one simple example.
Something we know is bad,
which is kind of fun.
Should have brought an
actual paper shopping bag.
You take a paper shopping
bag, they're mass produced
in this crease pattern,
so they're produced flat,
I believe.
And can't be folded,
doesn't fold rigidly.
You just have these
creases-- the edges
of the bag, this
kind of simple thing.
It looks like straight skeleton
over here, and a perpendicular.
Looks very nice from a
fold and cut standpoint.
And it does have a folded
state, which is flat.
There's no way to get there.
If you look at all the
possible folded states
of this pattern with rigid
panels, there are two.
There's the 3D state
you should see here.
There's the flat state.
There's nothing that could
possibly connect them.
There are no other states,
so there's no folding motion
from one to the other.
You could
instantaneously be flat,
and you could
instantaneously be open,
but you can't do
anything in between
without curving the paper
or doing something invalid
according to rigid origami.
So obviously you don't want to
make a paper shopping bag out
of metal, I guess is the
lesson, without adding
extra creases at least.
Yeah.
I would love to find more open
questions on rigid origami,
but so far we've just looked
at a few small things.
But this turns us
over to linkages,
which are all about finding
these motions without making
extra creases.
So I need to introduce a
little bit of terminology.
This is like creases
and all those things
from the origami world.
But we care about various
levels of linkages.
Let me remind you,
in general a linkage
is going to be something
like these guys.
This is the Peaucellier
linkage, these guys
were pinned to the
projector screen,
these guys were flexible,
these are rigid bars,
and this guy ended up
tracing a straight line
as this thing moved.
So that's the thing we want
to map-- model mathematically.
We're going to have
zero thickness, just
like with paper folding.
We're going to have vertices,
where things come together.
And we're going to have edges,
which are those rigid bars.
And I'm going to try to
speak in two languages at
once-- the fairly
intuitive one, and I'm
going to use some
notation in parentheses.
So if you follow
the math, great.
If not, also fine.
The graph is just
combinatorial structure.
It just says, look, I've
got things joined together
like this.
There's no geometry,
there's just
a sense of what edges are
joined together at vertices.
It's an abstract thing, kind
of like the shadow trees
we work with.
They're not really
embedded anywhere,
though here, you don't
even have lengths.
Linkage, you assign lengths
to the edges, and that's it.
So I take a graph and then
I add lengths to edges.
Its lengths of edges.
So in math, this
would be a function l
that maps every edge to a
non-negative real number.
And I might want
a little bit more.
So this is sort of optional.
You might have some
pinned vertices,
things that are not
allowed to move.
So you might add coordinates
for pinned vertices.
And so in math, this
would be a function p
that maps some subset
of the vertices E
prime to wherever
you happen to live.
So here, I'm supposing our
linkage lives in d dimensions,
because we're going to think
about linkages in 2D today.
We're going to think about
linkages in 3D, linkages in 4D,
and higher.
Everything is fair game.
We're going to be
pretty general.
And sometimes, I want to
think about the linkage
as this abstract thing.
It tells me how
things are connected,
tells me what the lengths are.
This is again like
a shadow tree.
Maybe I'm also told
some vertices are pinned
in particular places in the
plane or in 3D or whatever.
But sometimes I want to
forget about that extra stuff
and just think about the graph.
We won't do that
'till next lecture,
but I mention it now
because we will need it.
And then where
the real action is
is in the configuration
of a linkage.
And that's the geometry,
that's how the thing is folded.
This is basically a
folded state for linkages.
Why is it different
terminology than folded state?
Just because it's a
different sub-field, I guess.
Avoid confusion with
the other notions.
With folded states,
usually we allow creases
all over the place.
With the linkage, you're
really only allowed
to bend at the vertices,
so it's a bit special.
So a configuration
just gives you
coordinates for every vertex.
So we would say configuration
C maps every vertex
to some point in d
dimensions, and you
have to satisfy a
bunch of constraints.
And the constraints are
given by the linkage,
so you've got the lengths
and you've got the pinning.
So you have to have that.
If you look at two vertices
that are connected by an edge,
that edge has a
length, the distance
between those two
points should be
equal to the length of that edge
as given by that function l.
This is for phi w an edge, and
then for the pinned vertices
the point you choose
better be exactly what's
given by the pin function.
Never mind the details,
it's pretty intuitive.
But link-- whenever
I say linkage,
I mean the abstract thing.
Configuration, I mean actually
embedded in whatever space
you're living in.
So let's do a simple example.
Basically, the simplest
linkage that you can think of
is a square, and abstractly just
a bunch of vertices and edges.
This is the graph.
I haven't written down anything.
When I add lengths-- let's say
they're all the same length,
I want to represent a square--
that becomes a linkage.
And maybe I also specify this
guy is at coordinates 0, 0;
and this guy is at
coordinates 1, 0 that's
one unit away from this point.
So that would sort
of pin things down,
and these guys are
still available to move.
This is of course not
a valid drawing, not
a valid configuration
of the linkage.
The lengths aren't
all the same, this guy
looks longer than this one.
But then a valid configuration
would be an actual square.
I should draw in the plane.
Let's say-- so this is
at 0, 0; this is at 0, 1;
this is 1, 1; 1, 0.
So that's a configuration.
There are a bunch of
configurations this linkage.
For example, that would
be another configuration.
And there's a whole
degree of freedom here.
And we really care about all
those different configurations.
We call that the
configuration space.
Configuration space is the
set of all configurations.
So it has one thing
for the square,
there's one thing for this
particular parallelogram,
and there's that whole picture.
Why don't I show you
graphically what it looks like?
So here we have a
square-- square, move.
There we go.
So yeah, it's flexible.
That vertex C is
moving around a circle.
We can go around, and
around, and around.
All right, you get the idea.
Are there any other
configurations?
No or yes.
Pick one.
Yes is correct.
Ah, yeah, there.
So when I get to here
and everything's sort
of overlapping--
little hard to see,
but you see there's
the yellow and green.
Then I can bend--
and this I can't
do in the way this
program's set up-- I
can now move d
without moving AB.
I could move the segment
BD and spin that around.
So in fact, if you think
about it for a while--
I hope I got this
right, because I
think every time I've
given this lecture
I draw a different picture.
The space, the
configuration space,
it looks something like
three kissing circles.
So it's not quite
drawn to scale.
Each of these points
I want to correspond
to one configuration.
I should really draw this
with more board room.
All right, so we
started with the square.
And let's say these are the
pinned guys on the bottom.
I had this one circle
of motion, which
just moved this segment
around sort of in a circle.
So at the opposite point would
be where these guys are pinned
and the square is inside out.
And halfway along
would be I don't know,
let's say I'm going left
here, I've got this,
and then my square is over here.
Draw the right number
of points, yeah.
And over on this side would
be these are the pinned guys,
and my square is over there.
From here, I can
do another circle
of motion, which is I can
never move these points,
but now I can turn
this guy around.
And when I go halfway
around it will
be sort of folded on itself.
So these are the
pinned guys, and then
the polygon's like that,
all on top of itself.
We're only thinking about
where the vertices are,
we're not thinking about
overlap order here, one
of the differences
with linkages.
And if I go around
from this guy,
it turns out-- I'm pretty
sure these circles of things
are different except right here.
And so this thing is
equal to this thing.
So hence, three circles
that, pairwise, kiss, I
think is the topology
of this space.
You can walk around this thing.
It was a little hard to
draw, but in this very simple
example, we can draw effectively
how the configuration
space works, how you
can navigate operations.
In general, I want points
in the configuration space
to correspond to
configurations of the linkage.
and I want paths in
the configuration space
to corresponds to motions.
This is actually the first time
we get a definition of motion.
I haven't specified one
here, although motion is just
going to be a continuum
of configurations,
just like we had with paper.
In the configuration
space, a motion
is just some path
through the space.
You start at some point.
You end at some point.
There may be multiple
ways to get there,
but if your thing is
connected, there's
a way to get from
anywhere to anywhere.
We want to understand
the structure
of paths in that space.
That's motions.
That's how you can get places.
Mathematically, I guess
this is one big parenthesis,
you can think of a conflagration
of an n-vertex linkage
as a bunch of coordinates.
You've got the coordinates
for the first vertex,
coordinates for v1, so
if we're in d dimensions,
there's going to be
d of these things.
So you've got, x, y, whatever.
Then you could write down
the coordinates for v2.
Let's say we're in
three dimensions.
So we've got three
here, three values here.
I'm not going to write
down what they are,
because I don't know
what they are-- then
three values for
the third vertex,
and so on for n vertices.
Why is this useful?
Because you can think
of a configuration,
specify all these coordinates.
How many coordinates in total?
It's d times n numbers.
You can think of a configuration
as just d times n numbers.
So you can think
of a configuration
as a point in d times
n dimensional space.
So this is giant space.
Like for our square, I drew it
as a two-dimensional diagram,
but in reality
there's four vertices.
Each has two dimensions.
So it's an eight-dimensional
space-- a little hard
to imagine.
But it's so constrained--
you can't just
take any set of numbers here.
They have to satisfy the
edge length conditions,
and they have to satisfy
the pinning constraints.
And by the end, the space
is locally one-dimensional.
It lives in eight
dimensions, but you can only
move along
one-dimensional curves.
So we say this
configuration space
or that these configurations
have one degree of freedom.
And "degree of
freedom" is probably
a term you've heard before.
It's used all over the place.
And the formal notion
of degree of freedom
here is just, locally, how
many dimensions do you have
if you look at the paths
going out from where you are?
If, for example, I have
just a free segment,
it's got a bunch of dimensions--
a bunch of degrees of freedom.
It can translate,
and it can rotate.
I guess, three.
If I pin one of the
vertices, now it only
has one degree of freedom.
It can spin around.
Just locally, how many
different ways can you move?
What is the dimension
of your space?
And a lot of the time,
we care about things
that have only one
degree of freedom
because they're controlled.
We get to say what they do.
All right.
Let's move on to something
interesting about all this,
which is Kempe's
Universality Theorem.
So this is the result that
you can sign your name, so
to speak, but I'll
state it more formally.
My input is an algebraic
planar curve, and all of this
can be generalized to
beyond two dimensions,
but I'll start with
the planar case.
Let me get back to that.
Think of that as
just this blind,
some kind of polynomial curve.
We're going to restrict that
curve to a bounded disk,
then claim that is
exactly the trajectory
of some vertex in a linkage.
OK.
So I have a lot of
things to define here.
One of them is trajectory.
So this is pretty intuitive.
So for example, you take some
linkage like this square,
and as it moves, you just
follow one of the vertices.
So for example, if we look
at c, the trajectory of c
is this white circle, at
least as we move to here.
I think even here, when
we move d, c doesn't move.
So the trajectory
of c is that circle.
It's just-- you take
all the configurations,
but then you just
focus on one vertex
and see where it
can go in the plane.
In general, it can be very
complicated, like here, maybe.
Yeah.
You may recall it seems
I do this every time.
If you look at the trajectory,
this is not actually a vertex,
and that is not a valid color
if you want to see something.
This vertex, for
example, its trajectory
is some kind of figure
eight curve like that.
In general, it can
be some crazy curve,
and we want that crazy curve
to match a given planar curve.
What is this notation?
All I mean, it's just
something like 3x cubed times
y minus 7y to the
fourth power equals 0.
You can also add 23 to it.
Whatever.
So you have some equation.
This is an equation on points.
In general, if you
think about it,
you've got two degrees
of freedom for a point.
It has an x-coordinate
and a y-coordinate.
You add one equation,
one constraint,
that effectively pins it
down to be one-dimensional.
So it's going to define
some one-dimensional curve.
It could be very general.
It could even be disconnected.
All sorts of weird stuff.
But you can use this to write
down circles and ellipses.
That's the quadratic
polynomials.
But you could also write much
more complicated things here.
So this defines some
crazy curve, locally
one-dimensional thing.
And it may also go off to
infinity if there's hyperbolas,
or whatever, in there.
We're not going to try to
capture the infinite curve
because that's
actually impossible.
If you have any pin
vertex, then you
can only get so far away
from that pin vertex.
If you have no pin
vertices, then you
can show you can make
any point in the plane.
So if I want to get a
one-dimensional set,
it's got to be a bounded
set from a linkage.
So I take some big
disk that captures
the stuff I care about in
that one-dimensional curve,
and then I am going to
trace out everything
of that curve inside that disk
using one vertex of a linkage.
That's my goal.
So it's a pretty
powerful result.
I like to call it Kempe's
Universality Theorem
because Kempe wrote a paper
about it in 1891 or so-- 1876.
Even earlier.
He didn't really prove
the theorem, though.
Kempe is quite famous for
two wrong proofs of theorems,
but the theorems are true.
The one he's most famous for
is the four color theorem,
which you may have heard of.
Any plane or map can be
colored with four colors
such that no two
countries share boundary
if they have the same color.
He didn't prove that theorem,
but it was the late 1800s.
It wasn't proved
until 1960 or so.
But the technique he used is
called the discharging method,
is the proof that
people use today.
There are now two proofs
to the four color theorem.
They both use discharging.
So they both use Kempe's ideas.
He was just ahead of his time.
He also claimed to
prove this theorem.
And he proved a slightly
weaker version of this theorem.
I'm going to show you his
proof because it's nice,
and it can be fixed,
actually, relatively easily--
although that was done only in
the context of this class six
years ago.
So Kempe's proof has been
around for over 100 years.
Other people had
proved this theorem
but in more complicated ways.
We can prove it in the
same way Kempe did,
just a little bit of extra.
So the rest of the lecture will
be about proving that theorem.
All right.
So we've got two things
we need to worry about.
We have to worry
about this curve,
and we have to worry about
being in a bounded disk.
I like being in a bounded disk.
That sounds really easy.
Let's start with that.
So this is this figure.
I have, just for fun, a scan of
the original Kempe paper where
he draws the
corresponding gadgets.
This is, again, a gadget proof.
We're going to have lots of
cool gadgets to do fun things.
A rhombus looks like this.
It has one pin vertex,
a, here, and you
have a degree of freedom in
how you specify this thing.
You specify the lengths of the
edges, but all of the edges
have the same length.
So it's like a square, except
I only pin one of the vertices.
That's really the same thing.
And you can see, it can only
go out to twice that distance,
and then it fails
to exist out here.
These figures are drawn using
a program called Cinderella,
which is very, very cool.
It's commercial, but
you can download a demo
and make your own fun
constructions like this.
These are all on the web,
the ones I drew here.
So you can see,
basically, that point b
is constrained to lie in a disk.
That's it.
Very simple.
So that's the rhombus gadget.
But I want to think
about it a little bit.
So this vertex is pinned,
let's say, at 0,0.
Well, I guess it's pinned
at the center of the disk.
I don't know where that is.
This vertex is going to be
the vertex I care about.
It's the one that I want to
force to lie on the curve
and trace out the curve.
This is going to
be my magic vertex.
Let's call it x,y.
Say the point that
it lives on is x,y.
I somehow have to evaluate this
multinomial, various powers
of x and y, multiply
them by some constants,
add them together, and
force that to equal 0
by some constraint, by
adding-- bars, in general,
are constraints.
Edges are constraints.
They give me
equality constraints.
I say the distance
between these two vertices
is equal to something.
Somehow I have to set up the
distance between two vertices
to be that crazy
function that I'm given.
It could be anything.
It could be a mess.
So Kempe had this cool idea.
He said, look, you
can write this point
as a sequence of motions,
you can think of them.
So you start at the
origin here, and then you
move along this segment,
and then you move
along this segment.
So let's just write
down-- what's that angle?
Call it alpha.
Let me be consistent
with my notation.
Yes, alpha.
And these are horizontal lines.
And you can think of this
angle-- I'll call it beta.
So there's some length here.
Did I give it a name?
I do.
I call it r/2, because
if these are both r/2
and these are also r/2-- that's
the definition of a rhombus--
then this point
can get to anywhere
within a disk of radius
r centered at this point.
So this would be the
center of the disk.
So we're given r, we're
told what the disk is.
We set this up.
But now alpha and beta
are in some sense free.
They're actually
related to-- no,
they're not even
related to each other.
This point still has
two degrees of freedom.
Even though it can't
go out to infinity,
it can move in x and
it can move in y.
We saw because only
one point was pinned,
it could float around in
a tw-dimensional space.
So alpha and beta are actually
both free to some extent.
So instead of
coordinatizing by x,y,
you could coordinatize
by alpha and beta.
And you can relate those two
coordinatizations by some trig.
I'm going to cheat
here because I never
remember which is sine or
cosine without thinking
for 30 seconds.
The way I remember
is always cosine
is alphabetically
smaller than sine,
and so cosine is
the x-coordinate
and sine is the
y-coordinate, if you
draw the triangle in the
conical orientation, which
you might forget.
If you were given
these angles and you
want to construct
this point, it's
like, well, I go
in this direction.
That direction is cosine
alpha, sine alpha.
And I go that direction
for r/2 distance.
So I have r/2 times cosine alpha
in the x-coordinate, r/2 sine
alpha in the y-coordinates.
It's nice and alphabetical.
Then from there, I
go in this direction,
which is in the beta
direction-- the cosine beta,
sine beta direction.
I go that direction by
the same amount, r/2.
So there you go.
That's x and y written in
terms of alpha and beta.
For the purpose of this exercise
I prefer cosines over sines.
So I'm going to
rewrite these sines
in terms of cosines
in the obvious way,
which I will look up, which
is cosine alpha minus pi/2,
Those r/2 cosine
beta minus pi/2.
OK.
Let's see if I can successfully
draw cosine and sine.
Sine starts here and does that.
Cosine starts here
and does that.
They're just shifts
of each other, which
I didn't draw so beautifully.
Something like that.
Cosine and sine,
just a shift by pi/2.
So if I subtract
pi/2 from the angles,
I can turn it into a
cosine instead of a sine.
Great.
So I have x and y
written as cosines
of things involving
alpha and beta.
So what?
Well magically, when I think
about squaring or raising
x to some power like 10, if
you look in angle space what
happens to alpha
and beta, it's kind
of like multiplying
the angles by 10.
In some sense, going into
the trigonometric world
is like taking logarithms
if you're into algebra.
You have these exponents, and
they're hard to think about.
You take logs, it's
just multiplication.
No biggie.
And for those of you who
know complex analysis,
that should be obvious.
For the rest, just
take it on faith,
and we'll just find
out that it's true.
Because you have
this good friend.
You have the product
of two cosines.
You can rewrite it in terms of
adding and subtracting angles.
Now, you may not have
learned it this way.
You probably learned
about rules for cosines
of sums of things and cosines
of differences of things.
If you take these two
expansions, add them together,
lots of things
cancel, and you end up
just being left with cosine a
times cosine b with a module
a factor of 2.
So in our situation, we
have this crazy thing.
Let me write down another
one-- x to the seventh times y
squared plus whatever,
maybe times 6 here.
Well, I know what x and y are.
I just expand them.
I can just plug in
this thing involving
cosine alpha and cosine beta
into x, and plug in this thing
involving cosine of alpha
minus pi/2 and so on into y.
Multiply all that stuff out.
What you end up doing is
multiplying cosines times
cosines.
And here's how we do it.
To multiply two cosines, I
absorb things and turn it
into cosines of sums of angles
and differences of angles.
And I brought an
example for you.
I'm from Waterloo,
so I use Maple.
You could use Mathematica,
whatever you want,
because doing this
algebra is a pain.
But at the top there, it
says substitute x equal
that crazy thing and y
equal that crazy thing.
Here I didn't bother
rewriting in terms of cosines
because Maple's smarter than I
am, so I don't need to do that.
And I have some crazy
equation at the top
there, which is x cubed
times y minus 5 times x times
y squared equals 0, but I'm
ignoring the equals 0 part.
So I just plug that in, and the
first time, the first answer
there, it doesn't do anything.
It just plugs it in.
Then I say expand that, and
it does all this crazy stuff.
It multiplies all those things
out, uses binomial theorem
or whatever.
You get various new
coefficients out there,
but you get various powers
of cosines and sines
of alphas and betas.
And then I use the
magic operation
Combine Using Trig Formulas.
And combine means when you
have a product of two things,
try to make it one thing.
And that's just a way of telling
Maple to apply this formula,
but it does it for the sine case
also-- both cosines and sines.
And then you get this pretty
equation, or pretty left-hand
side I guess.
You get sines.
It's written it as
sines and cosines.
In our situation,
we're only going
to get cosines because I
was very reductionist here.
And it'll always be cosines
of various integer multiples
of alpha plus some
integer multiple of beta.
And then there'll be some
power of r out there.
It's no biggie.
In fact, we're told what r is.
We don't have to
think very hard.
We can construct r
to the seventh power.
It's not a big deal.
In fact, all of
these coefficients
are not a big deal.
We can just say 15
over 32 times r cubed.
We can just make an
edge that's that length.
The hard part is making
these things because alpha,
beta are variables.
They're not a fixed thing.
As this thing moves, we want to
be able to compute twice alpha
plus beta, and then take
the cosine of that thing.
Now taking the cosine
of a thing is easy.
It's just the x-coordinate.
If I have a segment that's
going in direction theta,
then the x-coordinate
of this thing
with respect to that
thing is cos theta.
This is what I've been
using all the time.
The y-coordinate is sine
theta, but x-coordinate
is cosine theta.
So if we can construct something
at an angle of twice alpha
plus beta, then we just
project onto the x-axis.
This length is cosine theta.
Done.
So all we need is to be
able to take an angle,
multiply it by some
integer like 27,
and we need to be able to
add two angles together.
And that's what Kempe does.
So he does it with
this crazy thing
called a contraparallelogram.
A parallelogram looks like this.
You see the parallelogram.
So it's a little more
general than a rhombus,
but not much more.
And then the contraparallelogram
is you take this diagonal,
a,y I guess it's called here,
and you reflect one side down.
And so the blue thing is
the contraparallelogram.
How does it work?
What does it do?
Well, I'm assuming the
left point there is pinned.
Actually, I'm assuming
both x and y are pinned.
And it just moves around.
It's kind of cool.
It has this great
feature that the angle
at a here between
the two blue segments
is the same as the angle at y.
And the angle at x is the
same as the angle at b.
You can see that
throughout the motion.
So it's basically
an angle copier.
Angle copier sounds
good because if I
want to multiply an angle by
2, I'd like two copies of it
and then stick them together.
So we're just going to take
this contraparallelogram
and combine a bunch of them.
So if we're going
to multiply by 2--
it's a little harder
to see right on blue.
So I have one
contraparallelogram here,
and then I make a similar--
you just scale it up--
contraparallelogram that
lies along that one.
So there's two
contraparallelograms.
And as I said
before, this angle is
going to be equal to this angle.
That's going to be
our input alpha.
And we're trying to
compute twice alpha,
which will be here.
And because this
contraparallelogram
is similar to this one,
the angles are the same.
It's just a blowing up of it.
So that means these angles,
which are equal to each other
because it's
contraparallelogram,
will be equal to these
angles because it's
the same contraparallelogram
scaled up.
Therefore, we have two copies
of the angle right there.
I'll just show
you that it works.
A little hard to see on a
digital screen with pixels.
Here.
When we get 90 degrees, we're
going to get the twice of it
is exactly 180.
Here's 45.
Here's two 30s
make 60, and so on.
It works basically all the time.
Wow, cool.
It's hard to see in some cases.
I guess there, twice 180
is making 360, and so on.
That's how you
multiply an angle by 2.
But then you can extend that and
just repeat this construction.
I take one contraparallelogram,
I attach it
to another similar
contraparallelogram,
I attach that to another
similar contraparallelogram,
I get three copies of the angle.
Amazing.
Here's trisecting
180 degree angle.
I get three 60s.
Wow, that looks crazy.
But it works.
This is sort of a
proof that it works.
It exists in all the states.
Great.
This is an angle
trisector, which
was a big deal in
the late 1800s.
You could build a linkage
where if-- instead
of thinking of this
as being your input,
or this, whatever-- any one of
these three could be the input,
and the output is
three times that.
That's what we want.
You could turn it around and
say, if I'm given some angle,
I line up these two bars
to be equal to that,
and then I'll get three
trisections of the angle.
You can use this to
quintisect an angle.
You can divide into
any integer number
parts using this crazy linkage.
Fun stuff.
And we can use it to multiply
an angle by some constant.
I should write, we
do this, we expand,
and we will get
a bunch of terms.
We will get that our
function phi here
is a sum of a
bunch of terms that
look like some constant,
which we can compute ahead
of time nothing's changing,
times cosine of some integer,
what do I call it, it's
to match minutes here,
r sub i times alpha,
plus s sub i times
beta, plus some
magic number delta,
and delta is 0, or plus
or minus pi over 2.
So that's not a big deal.
That's just saying whether
we're using sign or cosine.
What we need is to
construct, and these
are both integers could
be positive or negative,
negative's not such
a big deal, it's
just you look at the
angle the other way.
So we need some integer times
alpha, some integer times beta,
we can now do that.
Then we need to
add them together.
How do we do that?
We use the Kempe Additor.
There he is drawing it.
we drew a slightly more detailed
diagram, looks like this.
Now, this is a
little more confusing
so I had to label the thing.
We've got the x-axis,
I like that part.
The idea is we have two inputs.
Here's input one, defining
one angle to the x-axis.
Here's input two, another
angle to the x-axis,
here is about 90 degrees.
I want to add them
together and that
will be this output over here.
Our idea, I think I should
draw this separately,
not our idea this is
Kempe's idea, here's
0 here's input
one, and input two.
Both of these are measured
as angles to the x-axis.
All we need to do is sort of
rotate this angle to be here,
and then this guy
will be the sum.
How do we figure that out
when all we know how to do
is multiply angles by two or
divide them in half let's say?
I told you that.
You think about it
for a while, you
realize, oh well
let's instead think
of it as taking this
angle the smaller one,
doesn't really matter
but it's easier
to think about copying
that angle over here.
I want to copy that
angle over here,
and I'm an origamist
I think reflection.
I would really like to
reflect along the bisector.
Now what is it a bisector of?
It's a bisector of this angle,
which hasn't been marked here.
But if this a, this is b,
then this would be b minus a.
So I want to bisect that angle.
Really I want to
bisect the angle
between this edge and this edge.
How do I do that?
I use a Kempe
multiplicator, value of two,
apply it to this angle, then
I figure out that bisector.
How do I copy this
thing over to here?
Well I take this
angle and I double it,
I'll get that, actually that.
So I just used two
Kempe doublers,
one to have been one to double.
And I can we
possibly see it here?
I have this line marked middle.
That is the bisector between
the input two line and the input
one line.
How is it found?
Well it's here.
That's one part of the Kempe
halfer, doubler, whatever.
And it's attached to one
over there, similar one.
So it's attached on one side to
input two and on the other side
to input one.
And so therefore it
actually takes that angle
and it cuts it in half there.
That's what it does.
So now I have that
middle line and I
have another Kempe doubler
which is attached to the output
thing, and the middle, and
it's attached to the x-axis
to ground it.
So now we're taking this
angle and doubling it
and that gives us the output.
And you do it, and magically
thanks to Cinderella,
it does the right thing.
So as I move, here I'm
changing input one,
and I'm moving the output
and also this middle line,
it's staying a bisector there,
when they both get to 90
it'll be 180, and so on.
And I can change
and put two as well.
And once you build it it's kind
of clear that it will work.
There's a special
case of doubling,
but I can add any
two angles I want.
And what's fun is it also
works, I set it up for input one
being smaller input
two, but it works just
as fine the other way around.
I don't want to go too
big because I get out
of the screen.
There's 0 adding 0 to something.
Cool, huh?
Like magic.
So Kempe was really smart.
He knew about these linkages.
He wrote that book How
to Draw a Straight Line.
But he knew a lot
more about then
how to draw a straight line.
He could use, he could
add two angles, man.
Very cool.
All right, what's left.
Basically done,
for Kempe's proof.
I haven't told you what's
wrong with this proof yet.
Maybe you've been
thinking about it.
Then you just have to put
all these gadgets together.
We have a schematic
of it in the textbook.
So we started at the
top with our rhombus.
Not really drawn like a
rhombus there, but pretend it's
a rhombus, this guy.
I guess this is simplified
since we drew this figure.
So all the edge
links are the same.
We've got that
point p at the top,
that's the one we care about.
We've got the o in the bottom
left, it's pinned to the table.
And there's one gadget
I didn't talk about,
translators which is copies,
angles around, not too
big a deal.
Then we, in this case
say, we take alpha,
it's right there, we multiply
it by two, get two alpha,
take beta maybe add those two
together, we'll get twice alpha
plus beta.
And that is some angle
we want to measure
the x-coordinate of the
segment with that angle.
So we just make this thing
have the right length.
What length should it have?
Well we have this
cosine of whatever
of our angle in
our formula here.
And there's some
constant in front of it.
And for whatever reason
we have this constant 3a
squared times b, something
that we know how to compute.
So we just make this edge
have that length, that's
a scale marker, and
measure the projected
x length of that thing.
Well, in fact in general we have
a whole bunch of these terms.
We need to add them together.
We have a whole bunch of these
things you saw on the maple,
had I don't know, 20 of those.
So we just string them together.
That's our thing we start at
some point, which we call 0.
In fact, it will be the
same as that o, let's say.
It should be the same as that o.
We're going to measure relative
to the center of the disk
say, wherever 0 0 is.
And then we want to measure
how long this thing gets in x.
Some of these terms might
actually be negative,
some are positive.
But we're effectively adding
up all of these weighted sums
of cosines of our
angles which we
compute through
these crazy things.
At the end we want this to be 0.
So our goal is to make the
sum of all these things, which
is the sum of all these
things rewritten, equal to 0
That was the definition
of our curve.
How do we force it to be 0?
Well the actual value is
the x-coordinate here.
And I'm going to
force this to lie
on x equals 0 using a
peaucellier linkage,
because it forces
points to line a line.
In the way we drew
it, it would force
it to be on a vertical line.
So you have to imagine this
picture a little differently,
because in fact
this should be at x
equals 0, which is
normally right here.
So this thing actually
goes over to the right
and we'll get positive
and negative values
and it should lie along
the vertical line there.
And that's how you force, now
this point p prime has nothing
to do with them, is
not the same as p.
But we computed it based
on all these things
in terms of alpha and beta.
So this is a constraint
on p in the end,
because p determined
all these things.
And either this thing will
be on the line or not.
And we add this one
equality constraint
which would be exactly
this constraint.
It will constrain p
to lie on that curve,
and that's Kempe's construction.
Questions?
Three cool, just slightly wrong.
Any ideas what's wrong?
Has nothing do
with this picture.
It has everything to
do with the gadgets.
And actually it really has
to do with all this business
about the square.
I've lost my diagram of
the configuration space
to the square.
We had this thing that
when the square was flat,
it could fold in a new way.
And you saw I couldn't
even do that in Cinderella.
Cinderella is
designed to find sort
of one primary
arc of this thing.
But there are these
branch points, these guys.
And this construction
is perfect if you always
stay on your track.
But in a real linkage, you
can diverge at any point
and go to some other track, and
you can walk around this space.
When you have these branch
points where there's
more than two curves coming
together, you have a choice.
So you're not supposed
to have a choice here,
supposed to always
do this thing.
And sadly there's one
gadget, really two gadgets,
the parallelogram and
the contra-parallelogram.
The parallelogram
we're using here.
It's also used in the copy
gadget which I didn't show you.
What don't I tell you, a
copy gadget looks like this.
It's like a lamp, you
know like the Pixar lamp.
So if you have an angle here
it gets copied here, right.
These are just two
identical parallelograms.
So if you need multiple
copies of an angle,
you can make multiple
copies that way.
I don't think you really
need this, but Kempe used it.
It feels good to be
able to copy an angel.
And it's a parallelogram.
And we used a lot, the
contra-parallelogram.
The trouble is they
are the same linkage.
If you forget about
the configuration,
you just look at the linkage
which is who's pinned,
what are the edge links, what
is the graph connectivity,
it looks like this, just these
numbers are not all the same,
and only one of these
vertices is pinned.
Other than that it's
exactly this diagram.
You know, It's a square,
it's a quadrilateral,
has some lengths.
Opposite pairs are equal.
But you can't really
distinguish from the two
kinds of configurations.
There's one track which
is the parallelogram.
There's another track which
is the contra-parallelogram.
And you can do this.
Let me show you in animation,
give you some intuition.
So here I drew both, oh sorry,
not supposed to move that.
Here I drew both of them, got
the green contra-parallelogram.
And there's the, sorry green,
the blue contra-parallelogram.
And then we've got the
black and blue parallelogram
on the outside.
And ignore this diagonal, it
should be a different color.
And when we're flat,
that's the same thing.
And so we've got this one
cycle that goes around
and that's the blue picture.
Then at this point you can
switch into the black picture
and follow the parallelogram
around until it's flat.
And that point you could also
switch back to blue or not.
So I think this is two
circles joined to two points.
If I'm not mistaken,
the configuration space
would look like this.
So one of these tracks, say this
one, is a contra-parallelogram.
This one is a parallelogram.
They meet at the two
extremes, both flat cases.
And in Kempe's construction
he wants each of the things
that we call the
parallelogram like this one,
to stay on one, the
parallelogram track.
And he wants the
contra-parallelograms
to stay on the
contra-parallelograms track.
But how do you force that?
He didn't force it,
and so technically he
did not solve this problem.
He solved, that
solved this problem,
which is that you
would get exactly
the trajectory of a vertex.
He solved the slightly weaker
problem, which is his point
can travel along that curve.
It can also travel
on other curves.
But it's going to
be one dimensional
because it is constrained.
But there are these other
tracks you might conceivably
be able to go on.
In particular, you
can follow this track.
There might be other things.
And we'd like to
get rid of that.
It turns out you can get
rid of that pretty easily.
This problem was first noticed
by Kapovitch and Millson
in like 2002 I think.
Yeah.
Well that's when it
finally got published.
I think it was around for
a few years before that.
And they observed that
for parallelograms you
can fix it pretty easily
like in this picture.
You have the
parallelogram a-b-c-d.
You construct the
midpoints of a and b
and the midpoints of d and c.
How do you actually do this?
I want that point x to stay
on the middle of that bar.
You can do that
by making, if you
want to construct a point
in the middle of a bar,
you just add a tiny
triangle, where
it's forced to be that
way, where a b equals,
I mean the sum of a
and b equals a plus b.
And if you want,
do we need this?
I think you could just
construct those three bars.
This makes a little
bit more rigid,
but I don't think we
actually need that here.
So you can force a vertex
to be along the midpoint
there by making a tiny
triangle, a zero area triangle.
And when you do that, I don;t
actually have a picture of it,
we can look at the
countra-parallelogram I guess,
it forces the thing to work.
So for example, suppose
we go from the midpoint
here to the midpoint there.
That's going to stay parallel to
this segment and this segment.
It's like two parallelograms
joined together.
Okay, and if you went
here, and then you
tried to go off into the
contra-parallelogram state,
what would that do?
Well you'd have like from
the midpoint of this segment
to the midpoint of this segment.
Holy cow.
It's like they're right
on top of each other.
So that's not going to
have the right length.
Right now it's supposed to be
this length, same as the length
a x.
So if you try to jump
tracks you can't.
It's really easy to force
to stay on the parallelogram
track.
And then six years
ago in this class
I posed, hey can we
do the same thing
for the contra-parallelogram.
Kapovich and Millson gave
some other very complicated
solution.
Turns out there's also
pretty easy way to fix
the contra-parallelogram, which
is you add this pinpoint set up
to be--- So these midpoints
will all be aligned
because it's a
contra-parallelogram.
You take the middle
and you bisect,
you put x far away, it would
be very far down there.
And you just make these
lengths be what they should be.
And it's not so
obvious but you can
prove that as the
contra-parallelogram moves,
these edges will all
have the same length.
It works.
Whereas if you try to go
into the parallelogram state,
and you measure
these links, they're
going to be really tiny.
Here they're really large.
Am I doing that right?
What am I measuring?
No, the point is it's
not about those links.
These guys have to be co-linear
in the contra-parallelogram
case, but they are not collinear
in the parallelogram case,
and this is essentially
forcing that co-linearity.
So I don't want to go into the
details of how that's proved,
it's in the textbook.
But this bracing will force it
to say contra-parallelogram,
that bracing will force
it to be a parallelogram,
and then we actually
have proofed
Kempe's universality theorem,
with just a slight tweak
to his proof.
So that's the bug and the fix.
Let me tell you some
generalizations,
some open problems,
some applications.
Maybe start with
the obvious stuff
which is something called
Weierstrass approximation
theorem, which is that if you
have any continuous function,
I should say let's
think of it as a curve,
has an epsilon approximation
as a polynomial.
OK, so in particular
what this tells
us is if we have some
crazy curve we want
to make, like signature,
then you can approximate it
by a polynomial of the form that
we analyzed, this [INAUDIBLE]
of x y equals 0.
And the polynomial will
actually look like this,
It's a little bit
ugly, if you've ever
seen these constructions.
But it will be always within
an epsilon thickness of Eric,
always Eric, never
any other curve.
All right so you can apply
this to make your signature
or make whatever crazy
curve you have in mind.
That's kind of nice.
So this is why you can sign
your name using polynomials.
So that's an easy application.
Some generalizations.
All right.
You can do curves
in d dimensions.
We talked about two dimensions.
You can generalize that.
You can also do surfaces
in d dimensions.
Basically if you want to specify
a curve in three dimensions,
you need two equations
to constrain it down
to a one dimensional thing.
Generally you start
with d dimensions
and you can remove however
many dimensions you want.
You'll get some
subsurface in there.
Just add a bunch of
polynomial constraints.
You can do that.
Other fun facts.
The number of edges you
need is about n to the d.
This is being careful
about reusing structure.
In the plane you can deal
with n squared edges.
And that's optimal.
You can show you
need n squared edges
to construct certain
polynomials in the plane.
In three dimensions you're
going to need more, turns out.
Basically, because the
constructions we used
want to work in a plane, and
if you live in d dimensions,
you have to add lots
of edges to force
it to live in two dimensions.
So you can do the computation,
add the numbers, and so on.
What other good things?
All right, for the
mathematicians,
you can make any compact
semi algebraic set.
It's basically a
fancy way to say
you can add polynomial
constraints,
but you can also take
unions of solution sets.
So I could take the
union of five curves
that I like, or I can take the
intersection of five curves
that I like.
Bunch of things
you can do, that's
the meaning of semi
algebraic set, polynomials
and union and intersection.
These are all proved in paper
with Tim Avit and Reid Barton
from this class six years ago.
Another fun fact
from that paper is
that it's coNP-hard
to test rigidity.
Rigidity is the
topic of next class.
You're given a linkage,
does it move it all?
And you can use
these constructions
to mean, to show that something
will move at all if and only
if all these polynomials
have a solution.
And that turns out
to be really hard.
And it's something
called coNP-hard,
which is almost the
same as NP-hard.
it's just for rigidity,
it's really easy
to prove that something is
not rigid, you just move it.
It's a little harder to show
that it can't move in any way.
So that's for those who know
coNP, it's coNP, not NP.
Cool.
Those are various
generalizations.
Big open problem
here is what if you
forbid the edges from crossing.
This actually came
up in lecture one.
Someone asked it.
It was first posed that I know
from Don Shimamoto in 2004,
I was giving a talk.
And all these
constructions, especially
the contra-parallelogram,
need to have
edges that cross each other.
Next class will also
be about the case
where edges cross
each other but soon
we are going to
enter the case where
edges are not allowed to cross.
Can you do any of
this stuff, construct
any interesting polynomials?
Even constructing a straight
line, I think is open.
The peaucellier linkage
definitely doesn't work.
Maybe there are
some other linkages,
we'd have to check them.
But definitely Kempe's
universality result
is open for non-crossing edges.
I have some fun
projects like it'd
be fun to implement
this algorithm
and see this thing run.
You could build a sculpture
out of Kempe linkages.
They're a little
bit tedious I would
say to make interesting curves,
but there's some cool ones.
Like in the notes I have a
link to the letter C made out
of a linkage.
You could do a whole
alphabet, be kind of fun.
Have these things cranking
around and spelling
all sorts of, actually spelling
names would be the idea.
Another fun application that I
thought I would just throw in.
If you are, back to origami.
Origami can in some
sense simulate linkages.
And the motivation for
this is you've, you
know you've designed, you just
design all these awesome tree
maker diagrams for
your problem set.
And you realize, oh
man, there's points
all over the place on
this piece of paper.
How the heck am I
going to find, if I
had to make origami
diagrams, first I say,
oh you do this step, then
this step, then this step.
How am I going to tell someone
oh, just fold to root 3 over
7 comma root 5
plus root 7 over 4,
Which you could figure
out in some sense
from those geometries what
all those coordinates are.
How do you tell
someone to fold there?
Well, you could
use a polynomial.
Could say oh, you've
got to construct root 5.
Or what's a tough one?
Let's say you want to compute
the fifth root of 103.
Is that prime?
I think so.
So some nasty thing like this.
You say oh well, I
would really like
x to the fifth to equal 103.
If I could solve
this polynomial,
then I could
construct this number.
How do I solve that polynomial?
Well I'm all about solving
polynomials using linkages.
I could build a crazy
linkage device out
of my piece of paper.
Don't try this at home, please.
But in theory, you could come up
with these n really long bars,
fold them around, and
think of them as linkages.
And you tell people, oh well you
just need to align these dots,
you may make little pinches on
at the ends of these things,
those simulate the
edges of your linkage.
And then you just tell people
to move these creases around
until this point
lies on some line.
And then you've solved
your polynomial.
And this is a natural
generalization
in some sense to something
called origami axioms, which
we will probably talk
about at some point.
Usually you think about
doing one fold at a time.
You want to make one fold
so that this point maps
onto this line, and this
point maps onto this line.
That's the typical
origami axiom.
It's pretty good.
It can trisect angles
and it can do fun things.
But it can really only
solve degree four equations.
You want to solve a
degree five equation,
you need some higher
level techniques.
And one way to do that is
with Kempe's universality.
It's pretty impractical,
but at least in theory you
can do anything, you can
locate any point you want,
any algebraic point,
which are the things you'd
want from tree maker, using
this technique, little crazy.
There are other
ways to do it, too.
But this one way to do it,
as mentioned in the textbook.
Questions.
All right.
That's how to sign your name.
Next time we'll talk about
rigidity and other fun linkage
problems.